نبقى في مصر لكن ننتقل من القاهره الى
الاسكندريه ومع وقفتنا الثانيه مع مراسله
مساء العربي
مساء الخير يا سهام مساء الخير يا نادين
انا كان نفسي تكونوا معايا دلوقتي وتحسوا
قد ايه البحر مع
الاجواء الرمضانيه مختلف تماما عن حلاوه
البحر في الايام العاديه
[موسيقى]
طبعا في دلوقتي مبادره افطارك احلى على
البحر اللي اطلقتها الاداره المركزيه
للسياحه والمصائف
المبادره بتهدف اولا دي السنه الثانيه
المبادره والمبادره بتهدف لتشجيع اهل
اسكندريه انهم يتناولوا افطارهم على البحر
ويعملوا العزايم بتاعتهم على البحر
والتجمعات على البحر بدل الاماكن المقفوله
لان ده اكيد بيحسن ان الصحه النفسيه كمان
جدا وانا شايفه ان في عقبال كثير يعني
للناس فعلا كثير قوي دلوقتي بدات ان هي
تجيب
الملذه وطاب من مائده الرمضانيه ويتناولوه
على البحر ممكن ننتقل حتى
لاسرهم ونشوف قد ايه
يعني كان بودنا نحنا نتعمق اكثر ونغوص في
بحر شط اسكندريه بس على ما يبدو يعني اه
تمام رجعت اجمل
ندى انت خليك مكانك ما تتحركي العوده احمر
نتشرف بحضرتك دكتور وليد هندي استشاري
الصح النفسيه
[موسيقى]
دكتور وليد احنا عايزين نعرف اولا انتوا
بتتناولوا الافطار على البحر بشكل دوري
ولا لا ده طقس اساسي من طقوس الحياه من
ورا طفل صغير لحد النهارده وبالتالي حتى
انا بقول للاولادي انا بورثكم موروث ثقافي
ووجداني طب تعالوا تشبعوا بالطبيعه
بالطلاقه بالبحر الجميل ده حتى من الناحيه
النفسيه لما حد بيجي لنا عنده اكتئاب اقول
له زي ما قالت فايزه احمد ياما القمر على
الباب افتح اناديله اه افتح انت كمان
ناديله وشوف موجه رايحه وموجه جايه ودنا
عايشين في النص الحياه بين الاقبال
والاحجام وتاخذ منك وتديلك وبين نجاحك
والاخفاق او الفشل بين الحياه والموت
واحنا كمان عايشين في النص فمنظر البحر
الجميل ده انا بعتبره مستشفى نفسيه طبيعيه
ربنا خلقها لنا لازم نبقى حريصين عليها
عشان كده انا حريص ان انا اجي على الفطار
حتى في الايام العاديه غير رمضان بقى
اتغدى على الاقل يوم في الاسبوع واحنا
قاعدين كده هوت سايبين الدنيا واللي عليها
ورمينا والبحر زي ما انت شايفه كده والميه
والهواء
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات